good morning John last month I had a big
Twitter thread and then a vlog Brothers
video about the temperature of the
surface of the North Atlantic Ocean and
how it seemed to have increased at least
in part because we mandated low sulfur
Fuel and cargo ships and the sulfur had
been reflecting light and seeding clouds
which decreased the sunlight hitting the
ocean and how in effect we had been like
accidentally doing geoengineering and
maybe accidentally doing it would be
useful in figuring out how to
intentionally and thoughtfully do it and
some people got pretty mad some of them
for good reason mad enough that Radio
Lab called me and was like hey do you
want to talk about how that day went for
you as a way of exploring geoengineering
and we did that and that episode is out
and it's great and I'd love it if you
listen to it but look I knew that people
were going to get mad I just didn't know
how mad they were going to get some
people like felt betrayed by me because
the reality is geoengineering is the
most controversial idea in climate
science by far some people think that it
is criminal that we are not doing it
right now some people think that we
should ban even doing research on it but
I haven't been in that space for
professionally for a long time so I had
some catching up to do luckily a couple
of climate scientists who have YouTube
channels agreed to talk to me in a video
on Hank's Channel that I have just
uploaded Adam of climate adom and Miriam
of zuro talked me through a lot of the
global warming conversation and you
should definitely check that video out
and also their channels are amazing and
if you follow both of them you will be
among like the
99.9% most informed people on climate
change so you should definitely do that
it's low lift the content is super
accessible and great but I wanted to
make a video here this just sort of like
quick and dirty intro to why
geoengineering is interesting and also
so controversial and why I think the
fact that most climate scientists are
opposed to geoengineering is in fact
very good news first let's define the
term what is geoengineering the
definition is controversial but broadly
it's anytime you take an action to
intentionally change the systems of
planet Earth more specifically these
days when we talk about geoengineering
we're almost always talking about the
amount of heat in the system there is
other geoengineering like if you you
wanted to restart an ocean current if
you wanted to change ocean acidity if
you wanted to decrease the amount of
storms all those things would be
geoengineering now importantly intent
does matter because if it didn't then
the last 100 years of burning fossil
fuels would all be geoengineering we
would have been engineering the planet
to get warmer but it wasn't engineered
it was accidental we did it for other
reasons and so it's not geoengineering
it's just an oopsy it was initially an
oopsy it's not really an oopsy anymore
now it's like a stop hitting yourself
kind of situation so these days we're
mostly talking about intentional actions
taken to decrease the amount of heat in
the planet Earth system and importantly
there are lots of different ways to do
that we talk about geoengineering as if
it is one thing and it is not like
already we are doing some geoengineering
we paint roofs white and that like a
main benefit of decreasing the air
conditioning bills for those buildings
which also decreases energy consumption
but additionally it does reflect some
amount of energy back to space not a
measurable amount but that's part of the
reason why we do it so painting roofs
white is geoengineering but heading up
the ladder of complexity and impact and
controversiality here's an incomplete
list of other geoengineering things High
albo crops like crop plants that are
more reflective and lighter colors could
make the planet more reflective ocean
mirrors could reflect sunlight back to
Space Marine Cloud brightening would
seed clouds over the ocean reflecting
more light up high altitude Cloud
thinning would thin the wispy cirrus
clouds that actually do a better job of
trapping heat in this system then
reflecting it back to space and finally
stratospheric sulfur injection would
mean putting a ton of sulfur dioxide
into the stratosphere because those
sulfur particles are good at reflecting
light and they'd stay up there for a
long time each one of these has
advantages and disadvantages and as we
went down that list we got more
impactful and scary like high albo crops
would have a small and mostly local and
temporary reversible effect whereas
stratospheric sulfur injection would
have a large and Global and long-term
effect now the argument in favor of
doing these things and each one of them
is a solar radiation management
technique that's the term we use for
managing the amount of the sun's energy
that gets trapped in the system the
reason why we do that is because the
heat is a big part of the problem it's
not the only part of the problem like
ocean acidification would not be helped
by any of these things and that's also a
big problem but the amount of heat in
the system already is making life harder
on the planet and that's just going to
keep getting worse decade by decade for
a while and honestly we don't know
exactly how much worse it's going to get
and in fact that is another vote in
favor of doing geoengineering research
it could be that things get worse than
we expect faster than we expect and it
would be nice to have a tool in our back
pocket just in case we need it even if
we don't want to use it even if we're
not sure if it's going to work or we
don't understand all the harms it's
going to do the arguments against are
many and they are varied and I have sort
of different feelings about them
personally and I'm going to give them to
you as I understand them and this is
going to be biased first is this is
going to be good for fossil fuel
companies because they're going to do a
lot of this work whether it's like
moving carbon around or it's doing all
the chemistry that's necessary to do geo
engineering I don't care I look I want
to be on the record I do not care who
gets Rich saving the planet I would give
the guy I hate the most in the world all
of my money if I knew for sure he could
fix this problem I would hate it I would
hate to I'm thinking of who it is I
would hate giving him all that money but
I do it I might even say nice things
about him afterward maybe that would be
harder honestly but relatedly number two
this would be good for fossil fuel
companies because we'd just keep burning
fossil fuels forever if we didn't have
to worry about the heat if we could
manage the heat then we'd just keep
burning this doesn't worry me that much
cuz I just think it's wrong I recognize
that there are people who are like this
who are like we should just spend the
money to do the geoengineering and not
change anything but ultimately
Renewables are just better I would be
more worried about this if the cost of
solar and wind and batteries hadn't gone
down by like a thousand times since I
graduated from college but they have and
already in most ways they are better
better than fossil fuel infrastructure
and I think 10 20 years from now they
will be way better than fossil fuel
infrastructure and we just won't use
fossil fuels because they're worse now
on to the things I find more compelling
number one this is going to be by
definition a trolley problem what do I
mean by that I mean that if you're
trying to do something that's going to
help the whole planet there will be
areas of the planet that are harm the
scientists I've talked to are quite
uncomfortable with this they
understandably do not like the idea that
they might be put into a position where
they'll be asked to advise on whether we
should take an action that will like
Save A Million Lives but actually cause
the deaths of thousands of people and
this is like not abstract now for
clarity we already do this with
accidental release of carbon dioxide all
the time not accidental incidental we
make decisions here in America to
produce carbon dioxide and that's going
to have a negative impact on the world
and it will result in death and
suffering it's not a comfortable idea
but it's a real idea but we're not doing
it on purpose we're doing it so that we
can go visit our family in Indiana it
matters when you're doing it on purpose
and part of you thinks it shouldn't
matter but it does so say like lowlevel
example you just do some Marine Cloud
brightening you're just making it so
some low-level temporary clouds are over
the oceans and that increases the amount
of sunlight being reflected to space but
maybe the water that's forming clouds
there now would have formed clouds over
land and Fallen as rain and you're
creating a different rain pattern and
those people's crops fail so they don't
have the income they expect they don't
have the food that they expected and
there's a fan so yeah try problem
uncomfortable now we do that nationally
all the time like when we say we're
going to shut down a calf fired power
plant or we don't want as many calf
fired power plants that has negative
impacts on people but we do it CU it has
positive impacts on more people but
that's very different when that's one
country making decisions for itself than
if it's one country making decisions for
another country which leads me to the
second thing that is a good thing to
point out actively doing geoengineering
could cause War so say one country is
taking actions that's making it better
for the people in that country but it's
resulting in less rain falling or
flowing into another country and that
country has instability because of that
they're not going to like each other and
that feels intentional and different in
a way that having like the US and China
burn a bunch of coal and then having a
global impact doesn't and I'm trying to
get comfortable with the idea that the
way that it feels matters uh because the
way that it feels matters third if we
did it for a while and then suddenly
stopped that's very scary so basically
if we're doing this radiation management
the amount of heat that would be in the
system if we weren't is going up and up
and up but we're getting that heat out
of the system through radiation
management if one day through an
accident or a policy decision or the
fact that like one country was doing it
and the other countries were like you
need to stop if suddenly it all stopped
after having done it for a while climate
models don't like that that could result
in like a very chaotic series of events
for the planetary system there's even a
term for it it's called termination shot
that's scary both practically and cu the
term that's just a scary term that's a
good one Neil Stevenson next on the list
Miriam really drove this point home to
me and helped me understand it this
isn't a thing that should be done
unilaterally but it is a thing that
could be done unilaterally it's
inexpensive enough to do some pretty
large scale geoengineering that a single
country and not even a big one could
start doing also it's totally possible
that the countryes doing that would be
the ones who created the problems and
might be doing it without regard for
local impacts that would happen so you
want to do this in a way that involves
ideally all of the countries kind of
coming together and reaching some sort
of agreement and in a complicated system
like the Earth and complicated idea like
geoengineering that sounds very hard uh
and almost like it literally couldn't
happen but maybe it could like we've
done diplomacy on big hard things before
next and this is the second most
compelling of all of these arguments to
me we
actually don't understand this stuff
that well yet Miriam was talking about
how like of all the variables and
climate models the things that like
increase the error bar the most is
actually aerosols so like the effect of
particles in the air reflecting light
back to space that's a lot of what we're
talking about in geoengineering and we
don't understand yet very well the
mechanism of how that works and how it
much it does what it does and this isn't
just about like energy out energy in if
it was Just Energy energy in then we'd
understand it but what it's also about
is how it's going to affect the climate
system as a whole if we do stratospheric
sulfur dioxide injection and it
decreases the temperature of the planet
by a degree that would be amazing but
what if it also dried up the monsoon
season in Southeast Asia and then
hundreds of millions of people are now
food insecure when they were not before
if that's a thing that might happen you
don't want to do that which leads me to
the last most important thing on the
list of reasons to be very cautious
about geoengineering which is we just
got one planet this is the only one
we're already messing with it and that's
really scary and to solve the messing
with it Problem by messing with it is
understandably terrifying and I'm like
okay so we got to understand it better
and Adam makes a great point which is
that in order to do an experiment that
actually will tell you about the
potential impacts of geoengineering you
kind of already have to be
geoengineering when I made that original
video what was so compelling to me about
this Marine Cloud brightening that had
been unintentionally happening
reflecting extra energy to space cooling
the North Atlantic is that we'd been
doing it and it wasn't controversial
while we were doing it because we were
doing it on accident and so to me like
keeping doing it doesn't seem that scary
but maybe it is because like we keep
doing it in a different way it might
seem like blowing a bunch of sea water
into the air so that salt crystals seed
clouds would be a pretty benign way of
doing things but maybe it's not maybe it
sucks water out of the air that would
fall somewhere else maybe the salt that
seated those clouds would be a
significant amount of salt falling on
crop lands and thus making that crop
less productive over time as the salt
content builds up none of this is simple
the only thing more complicated than
like the earth's climate is the human
brains it contains and both of those
things are very important things to
consider when taking really big actions
like trying to intentionally affect the
systems of the planet but the most
hopeful thing I got out of this was that
for the most part climate scientists
don't think that we need to be doing
geoengineering yet because we're not in
that situation yet and what I hear a lot
on social media and from friends is that
we are in the most dire of circumstances
but when you look at what's possible it
does still feel possible to solve this
problem without resorting to
geoengineering which might very well be
a last resort which leads me to what I
think is a fascinating question is
taking carbon dioxide out of the air
solar radiation management cuz like yes
it is it would have been solar radiation
management to put it in there in the
first place if we done it with that goal
there is a kind of geoengineering that
everyone is in favor of which is
reducing the amount of methane and
carbon dioxide that is released into the
atmosphere and then reducing the amount
that is currently in the atmosphere and
just like with geoengineering there's a
long list of ways to do that that range
from controversial to non-controversial
but if is less carbon dioxide and
methane in the atmosphere there will be
less heat in the system we know this and
we are doing things as individuals and
societies to act upon that knowledge we
are not doing it as fast as I would like
there will be tremendous negative
consequences to not doing it faster at
least about this thing everybody who
knows what they're talking about on this
topic agrees on that and that's a nice
thing to have I've put the link to the
conversation that I had with Miriam and
Adam on Hank's Channel in the
description along with Adam's video that
he made about my video which is very
good and also a link to to both of their
channels because as I said if you follow
both of them you will be among the most
educated people on climate science in
the world and their content is so good
it's not complicated it's very
accessible and they know what they're
talking about and right now at p.com
there's a special bundle today's special
is the it is false to suggest bundle it
is false to suggest as some recently
have that the pus hot sauce should be
used on your cheets John in fact this is
a collaboration between two products
that can only be shipped within the US
which enables us to provide an excellent
deal for all who celebrate beus under no
circumstances do we encourage you to
smother this delicious spicy sauce on
the tiny seedlings and take a little
nibble that would be an absolutely Wild
Thing to suggest totally irresponsible
just get these two cool items for a deal
that's all John I'll see you tomorrow